it's a month since the death of Chris
Cabot 15-minute sequence of events that
changed this family's lives forever
the inquest into his killing opened and
adjourned today while the police
Watchdog carries out its investigation
that might take six to nine months
but outside the port his cousin flanked
by his mother and father filling the
weight of their grief Here and Now
my cousin Chris was very much loved by
us
his loss is with us every day
he had a bright future ahead of him
his first child was about to be born
that his life was caught short by a
police officer it's a tragedy
the court heard the iopc outlined the
events of the night in detail
information heard in public for the
first time
Chris Cabell was driving through South
London near camberwell Green before
being followed by police officers who
are in an unmarked vehicle with no
lights or sirens
the officers did not know it was him who
was driving the car
according to police logs the Audi was
recognized by officers parked at the
side of the 802 in camberwell Green at
around 9 52 pm
the officers then started to follow the
vehicle
at around 1007 PM Mr Kaaba made a left
turn from New Park Road onto kirkstall
Gardens
armed officers exited their vehicles and
approached the Audi
he was shot in the head by an officer
standing in front of the car
this is the street where a single shot
took the 24 year old's life following a
series of events that have left his
family asking for answers and action
the whole of the country needs to know
how something like this could occur
how can a young man sitting in a car
unarmed be shot in the head by a police
in 2022
for his family the hurt will always be
public
in a fight they see is far from over
shinki Marie K Sky News South London